[Music]
thank you
being
okay guys
can you hear me
let me just fix the chat one more time
because this is the wrong window I think
you see
if you can hear me hi Milan if you can
hear me just start typing in the chat
guys
okay perfect
let's see if everything is working
properly
no what is real what is fantasy what is
true and what is carefully fabricated
where voyagers commanding an impressive
but unstable Armada that sails towards
the unknown
okay okay
everything is working properly
um
uh let me see something
okay
guys join us uh if you're watching
please make sure that
um hi hi zerooks if you're watching
please make sure to also join on Twitch
because I'm live on Twitch as well
and as I said last time twitch is gonna
be in the future the main streaming
platform because I want to use YouTube
primarily for my videos but for now
because like most people follow me on
YouTube
uh we're gonna do live streaming mainly
on YouTube
uh last time the stream was uh really
good a lot of Engagement all of you were
amazing all the questions were great I
really enjoyed it thank you so much for
the donations you guys are amazing and
uh I feel that we learned a lot of
things and um
um I think this stream is gonna be even
better because
um
I have a lot of great videos as you can
see here
um prepared for you today
um what I want to do is like I'm gonna
start like last time I'm gonna start
with
um a video from uh that I posted two
months ago one of my videos I'm gonna
start analyzing it and
um
while analyzing it maybe we can Branch
out different topics depending on on
what I am discussing
um at a given point in time as you can
see I have repaired videos for you like
uh this interesting video
um titled what is consciousness so we're
gonna dive into Consciousness
um this interesting video of
um with Jonathan height why modern
America creates fragile uh children uh
the decline of friendship
um why you should want to Suffer Well
that's debatable but let's see what the
guy says
um why sex food and shelter aren't
enough for Homo sapiens
and the the this amazing Theory called
the stoned ape hypothesis or stoned ape
Theory which is like something
um I stumbled upon recently and I found
it very very interesting and we're gonna
dive into this and I think it's going to
be really cool
[Music]
is the first stream still still online
no it's not online because
um
um I didn't like some parts of it and I
think that
[Music]
um
this stream is going to be way better so
and I also don't know if I'm Gonna Keep
the streams online for a long period of
time actually you can find the first
stream on Twitch but but you cannot find
it on on
um on YouTube the streams on Twitch are
gonna stay live for two weeks
on YouTube I don't I don't know if I
enjoy the video and if I can actually
monetize it because a lot of the videos
cannot be monetized because
um you know I don't know if uh the
content that I'm showing to you is
copyrighted or not so let's see I I
don't I and I don't want to mix the the
streams with my uh main videos so we'll
see some some of the streams will be
available online on on YouTube but uh
most of them will not but you can always
check them later on Twitch so make sure
to follow me on Twitch you can see here
the the link metamorphosis uh 77 also
follow me on Instagram here and on
Twitter here I'm active on uh both uh on
all platforms I don't have Tick Tock yet
but maybe in the future Russian Johnny
hey man how's it going so anyway Let's
uh get things started so this video is a
video I uploaded
um two months ago it's titled sometimes
you open your eyes and reality feels
like a dream and I'm gonna discuss
aspects of reality and how sometimes the
absurdity of reality can consume you to
the point that you don't
um you cannot actually
distinguish between dream and reality
as you open your eyes and reality feels
like a dream you don't know what is real
what is fantasy what is true and what is
carefully fabricated where voyagers
commanding an impressive but unstable
Armada that sails towards the unknown
and unknown that is quite inviting but
also quite unpredictable the precarious
times that we created are here to stay
and we sometimes reduce ourselves to
Mere observers of an inevitable future
during such times the collective Shadow
grows bigger and it exposes us to our
own fragility Nietzsche famously wrote
God is dead God remains dead and we have
killed him must we ourselves not become
Gods simply to appear worthy of it we
want it to become gods and we got
devoured by our own vanity we reduced
ourselves to primitive instincts and
okay let's go back a little bit dead
Nietzsche famously wrote I'm sure I'm
sure that most of you are
um aware
of with um are aware of this quote by
Niche God is dead God remains dead and
we have killed him must we ourselves not
become Gods simply to appear worthy of
it so Nietzsche wrote that
um a few
um if you not a few years ago he wrote
that like a long time ago but it is one
of his most famous quotes
um because it was written during a time
where uh hello one it was written during
a time when uh religion was um the
predominant ideology so to speak within
society and Nietzsche was feeling that
this is going to change very soon so
that a lot people are gonna become way
more independent are gonna distance
themselves from God and
he saw that as something very dangerous
because
when we do not accept God anymore in our
lives what happens then you know there
is a huge responsibility that comes with
that and um he said that the only way to
move beyond that to after we decide to
quote unquote kill God is
to become Gods right that's how he
started you know
experimenting with the idea of the Uber
Mensch
which the idea of implements
um we will discuss about it in another
stream I have talked about it in my
video
um about the book that spoke zarathustra
um it's a very interesting idea and
um
but it's also a very complicated idea
because the idea of the Overman some
someone Beyond human is something that
has been um
um
this has been really really difficult
for people to understand and has been
subject to a lot of criticism throughout
time because a lot of social groups also
took the idea and tried to
manipulate it in order to um
um to create their own version of it
especially the Nazis try to do that so
it is quite difficult to understand what
it means to become God but simply put
nature wanting to say that becoming God
is always becoming the better version of
ourselves like transcending The Human
Condition everything that keeps us
limited uh to uh very
um limiting mode of being and there are
many ways to do that and we will examine
all uh all those ways throughout the
streams
it God remains dead and we have killed
him must we ourselves not become Gods
simply to appear worthy of it we want it
to become gods and we got devoured by
our own vanity we reduced ourselves to
primitive instincts and realized that
the road to theosis is no bed of roses
we cannot shy away from this truth
theosis uh probably you know it's a
Greek word Right theosis comes from the
Greek word Fels which means god so
theosis is the process of becoming a god
reality is unknowable forever hidden
behind the veil of our assumptions
preconceptions definitions and paradigms
our leaders really try hard to do the
best for us but inevitably get lost in
the translation of what is the best for
us some people are pessimists and some
people are optimists in the end nobody
really knows what the future will bring
we are surrounded by so many promises
and so much hot air that we're tired to
even think about all this we're lost in
a mishmash of megalomania ambition and
greed all these are just projections
projections of a lack of honesty towards
the real issues that we are facing Carl
Jung said quite elegantly about
projections the following the effect of
projection is to isolate the subject
from his environment since instead of a
real relation to it there is now only an
illusory one projections change the
world into the replica of One's Own
unknown face and it makes sense we
humans are greatly disturbed by fear
anxiety and uncertainty and in seeking
to become more existential angst we
sometimes anchor ourselves to irrational
and ignorant practices that of
receptitude and stability I mentioned
before that we think that our Voyage is
smooth but it actually resembles
something like a Mad Max narrative I
don't know if you guys know why I say
that like a Mad Max narrative Mad Mad
Max is a great movie and let me show you
the trailer of the movie actually
I am the one who runs from both so it's
in a dystopian future and Mad Max is the
protagonist you escape and they're
chasing him right in the desert
and
this is like whenever I see the movie I
think I think of
the current state of of of what is
happening in the world today because
it's like it's so crazy
um instead of having a smooth Voyage
let's say uh to the Future towards the
future we decide to embark on this
um
uh wild chase you know like whether it
is an arms race or who which country is
gonna grow faster
um and
it resembles a Mad Max narrative like we
are being chased by each other to reach
something elusive something that we
don't really understand and it's crazy
that's why I love this movie and uh
that's why I decided to you know draw
this uh this parallel
elaborate the unprecedented evolution of
Technology led to the expansion of our
growth practices in every level of our
societies we accelerated entropy and
increased the level of complexity in our
systems to the extent that we are unable
to control them we are actually running
faster than we can chasing something
abstract and incomprehensible yes we
want the Perpetual betterment of our
species yes we want to eradicate hunger
and poverty yes we want to minimize
inequality you
let me just uh pause for a second
because uh I just realized that
I
I didn't post the
um
I didn't post the right link to my
to my social media I'm just gonna post
real quick on on Twitter and then we can
continue the Stream
anyway hope you guys are having a great
day hope you had an amazing weekend is
anybody here from uh the previous
um
from the previous uh stream
a tongue twister name yeah where are you
from by the way
okay
just real quick
[Music]
okay I just posted on Twitter and
um
on second second post on Facebook
hope you can guys clear and hear me
loud and clear
okay just post it on Facebook everything
is
under control
okay
to achieve self-transcendence but we
need to take into account that we're not
omniscient beings with benevolent
mindsets we're still greedy we're still
hungry for power we're still
psychologically ill we're Belgium
Palestine welcome guys welcome welcome
we're still humans if there is one thing
that we learned from evolution is that
evolutionary changes take a lot of time
exactly evolutionary changes take a lot
of time and it's very difficult also to
witness an evolution in real time
um and the problem is that we humans are
so we want everything to happen fast you
know we want fast things in our lives
and we're not patient and because this
is the antithesis of evolution we get
into this weird mindset where we're like
nothing is changing and the world is the
same and the world is [__] and the world
like there's no progress but there is
always is happening but at the very very
slow pace and we we don't realize that
and instead of just like calming down
trying to you know uh Forge a better
future with a strategy we always
complain and we want to try and hack
Evolution as I say here
uh Mexico salutes
hello guys hello guys
to hack Evolution and I love Mexico by
the way I've never been I always wanted
to go transcend human nature as fast as
possible but most probably this will
backfire we don't necessarily need to
raise that fast our journey could be
quite smooth instead we choose to ride
mad Max's Interceptor constantly
tweaking it and pumping it so it can
maintain us on the desert yeah Mad Max
Interceptor is the um is the car right
so the car is like the world and we keep
pumping it in order to get to the desert
road as fast as possible because we
don't know what it is it's a desert road
like an endless desert with no
um a specific view inside right
Zimbabwe hi hi
for as long as possible that happens
because we are not sure of how to face
the unknown when facing the unknown
Panic is the first automatic human
response then comes acceptance then
comes adaptation then comes cooperation
in the face of danger our brain switches
to panic mode and we become even more
irrational than we already are but why
can't we escape this mental prison the
answer to this question lies in the
periphery of one's Consciousness we live
aimlessly breathe mechanically and act
in the surging Flux Of The
anytime yeah probably next
next year let's see Utah welcome welcome
sentence we forget to breathe properly
and act as rational agents instead of
primitive egocentric beings we can adapt
to new realities faster and better than
we actually expect if we take a step
back and look at the bigger picture
Panic should act only as an alarming
mechanism not as a survival mechanism
survival comes through cooperation and
caring not through panicking and despair
Carl Sagan once wrote in the course of
looking deeply within ourselves we may
challenge Notions that give Comfort
before the Terrors of the world let us
challenge these Notions now let's move
to caring a bit faster than usual we are
let's uh let's see that one more time
let us challenge
survival comes through because it's an
amazing course of looking deeply within
ourselves
in the course of looking deeply within
ourselves we may challenge Notions that
give Comfort sorry
before the Terrors of the world like
such a beautiful quote such an amazing
quote really
we may challenge Notions that give
Comfort before the Terrors of the world
let us challenge these Notions now let's
move to getting a bit faster than usual
we are in this together and we can face
the unknown together we know this we
just keep forgetting it and one of the
main reasons is the current version of
capitalism that we have adopted
capitalism prevailed after the Cold War
and for good reasons this is a small
critique on capitalism on the current
version of capitalism actually I will go
deeper in future streams but I mentioned
here I mention it here so you can get an
idea of what I mean
it is a system that attempts to
orchestrate Financial Freedom that is
predicated on the responsibility and
ambition of each individual in theory
this sounds great but in practice there
are some caveats to consider equality of
opportunity is indeed a freedom that we
all tend to celebrate however we need to
also realize that opportunity has
different levels depending on social
conditions the conditions in poor
ecosystems are clearly less favorable
than this in richly there is a great
book that you need to read the um Peter
Joseph is the name
what's the name of his book
the new human rights movement that's a
great book uh and it discusses in depth
what
um
what I just mentioned in the
in the video actually Peter Peter Joseph
is the creator of the Zeitgeist
documentaries which are my favorite
documentaries when we're gonna cover
them maybe in the future I have the link
here moving quote forward I don't know
if you guys have seen it but it's like a
Trilogy and the fourth one is coming I
think this year or next year uh it's an
analysis of
um
capitalism religion
um economics uh and the future what is
like a great alternative to capitalism
and how we can get there
systems regardless of the genetic makeup
of the individual this clear handicap
creates all sorts of problems especially
in highly populated areas where the
competition in the workplace and the
resource acquisition is high so
inequality becomes the norm in
capitalism and it is this inequality
that creates instability and
dissatisfaction capitalism is not a
Panacea it is a system inspired by our
own nature and this is the sad part of
the equation we think that capitalism is
the best system because we refuse to
accept that our nature could be flawed
we all exist in this bubble of
egocentrismen where we think that we are
so special and disregard that our lack
of humility and empathy might be the
source of the calamities we experience
we need to create refugees of beneficial
order that deny the idea of constant
antagonism and embrace the idea of
synergy despite
I mean
capitalism was created as as an
alternative alternative throughout
history as an alternative to monarchy
and to Communism right but the problem
is that capitalism hasn't changed in the
last let's say a hundred years or so and
it's a system based on constant
competition and although we understand
that competition creates quality and
progress and more products and
everything it's something that we also
subconsciously inherit as a trait within
society and it affects every fabric of
our social relationships social
interactions sorry so so
whether we like it or not it is a
problem and we need to confront it at
some point because it creates this
constant antagonism and sometimes we
fail to uh to work in Synergy and and
instead of like working together we
prefer to work separately and in a way
that we you know work in a constant
competition with each other
there are differences the key is to open
our minds to further possibilities and
refuse the pseudo comfort of passivity
exactly when I say the pseudo comfort of
passivity what do I mean I mean that we
are we're currently at in in a passive
state where we accept exactly whatever
the system is giving to us and this is
we feel comfortable in a way because you
know we make enough money we're happy we
have our comfort and everything but this
is not a real Comfort is it is some form
of pseudo-conference right because deep
inside we know that there are so many
problems within the system that we
constantly need to face and the more we
refuse them the more they keep piling up
and at some time you know reality hits
us very very hard
the passivity that leads to a dystopic
reality dystopias exist everywhere and
nowhere they are fed by our demons since
we mentioned that I have a great video
for the future
um for later I mean
uh
this one why it's it's about it's about
Last of Us the TV show I don't know if
you guys have seen it
um it's in a dystopic reality and I
don't know if there are any gamers in
the chat but I love video games and I
used to play lots of us it was like one
of my favorite games
and
um it's one of the greatest TV shows of
of our time I think and it's one of the
few TV shows that managed to create a
really good adaptation from the from a
video game
Dar projected outward as physical
Creations that reflect the color of
you need to see it and you need to see
it for sure inner World by 2030
depression will be the number one cause
of illness worldwide dystopias are
essentially a manifestation of our
depression if you walk in a city
regardless of where you are in the world
you will notice signs of both Utopias
and dystopias whereas dystopia has one
meaning bad place Utopia can mean both
good place and no place in other words
Utopia can be something ideal and
reachable but it can also be something
unattainable and non-existent like a
far-fetched dream so what happens here
is a word play and a perception play
let's go back a little bit this is very
important so people say that use the
word Utopia as something you know that
that means something very beautiful some
a place that is idyllic a place that is
perfect but essentially what it means
it's either good place or no place you
know something that doesn't really exist
very beautiful very very nice when you
understand the etymology of a word the
words Utopia can be something ideal and
reachable but it can also be something
unattainable monarchy had two children
who were built against the family
communism capitalism
uh I don't know I don't know what the
future will bring but
um
let's see let's see
non-existent like a far-fetched dream so
what happens here is a word play and a
perception play language is used as a
way to interpret the world and because
this interpretation has many faces we
play with words in order to ensure the
plurality of present and future
possibilities in any case dystopians and
Utopias constitute points of view even
in the most idyllic Place humans can
find the reasons to complain even in the
midst of chaos humans can
exactly in the even in the most idyllic
Place humans can find reasons to
complain where have like how many times
have you been in a great situation you
went like for a trip and you uh it was
like such a beautiful place and because
you couldn't stay present you were
constantly distracted by fears uh
thoughts yeah uh your work whatever that
is that was troubling you at a certain
point in time uh this idyllic Place
stopped becoming idyllic anymore because
you were bored and uh
I just wanted to say that because
um at the end of the day it's up to how
we perceive the idea and how we think
the way we think shapes
um read the reality around us
especially when it's when it comes to
very difficult situation for example
here I say that even in the midst of
chaos humans can maintain Stillness and
peace of mind that's so true even if the
whole world is collapsing around you if
you have the right way to to perceive
things to to stay present everything can
be under control
epigenetics
15 Stillness and peace of mind the fact
is that entropy will keep increasing and
we need to be constantly aware of this
the more entropy increases the more we
lose track of what is good yes yes
exactly not only the environment that's
what I'm saying mainly the perception of
the environment
known at the macro level that is a sign
that we need to bring ourselves back to
our own level of influence when we
operate in our own level of influence we
can overcome most of our fears even the
fear of death meditating on the fear of
death is quite a bizarre mental
challenge because it's not so much about
the fear of death itself for death is a
state of nothingness which as far as we
know has no connection to our current
state of being it is more about fear of
the unknown exactly
um it's so funny I don't know I think
you guys already know that I'm from
Greece right and I'm a big fan of
ancient Greek philosophers especially
Socrates I don't know if you guys like
Socrates I don't know if you read any of
his books
um any of his Works mainly Plato
actually because Plato is the one who
introduced us to Socrates but there is a
uh there is a
H let me find it actually
last words of Socrates
no no that's not it
uh wait I have a video on this
not leaders are public
oh yeah this apology the greatest Last
Words ever ever spoken
so The Story Goes Like This
the Socrates was like a very wise man in
in ancient Athens right and because he
was so wise he was constantly
questioning the status quo right and
um his ideas were a little bit
revolutionary for the time being he was
questioning the existence of gods or
this kind of things the the people in
power and the people in power didn't
like that so he was charged to like to
come to a trial
and
um he had to apologize for his sins
right and he went to the trial but he
knew that he was going to die they they
uh they sentenced him to uh to death by
poison and he had to drink the poison
actually do I to kind of kill himself
but his last words are kind of legendary
because he said that I'm not really
afraid of death because if you think
about it
if I die right there are two options the
one options is I'm gonna sleep and this
is gonna be like the kind of sleep that
is going to be completely undisturbed
you know it's the kind of slip that you
have when you uh when you don't see any
dreams and it's so so deep that you wake
up and you wake up like so well rested
that uh it didn't like it felt like the
most Serene uh mode of being ever right
which is if this happens I feel blessed
that's what Socrates said and the second
option is like uh if we believe that
there is a transition of the soul from
this uh world to the other because the
ancient Greeks believed in um I believe
in the Underworld uh he said that uh in
this world I'm gonna meet all the people
from history and especially people that
I admired you know ancient Greek Heroes
like Achilles or
um Homer or
Ajax and I'm gonna have amazing
discussions uh with them until the end
of time that's like a more romantic
approach to the um to the idea of death
but it's very interesting to meditate on
on this idea I think in such a way
because here
um I mentioned the the uh yeah how
people
um
try to battle the the fear of death and
most of the time it's it's impossible
but uh you can think whenever you you
you're you're having like
um this kind of
um
thoughts in your head you can think of
Socrates I think
which is a Perpetual condition
throughout life and it is this
perpetuity that creates States like
existential angst and general anxiety
disorders anxiety is disturbing because
it is free-floating it is not like fear
fear is quite specific specificity can
be tackled because we narrow our Focus
to something that is within our scope of
understanding anxiety emerges from the
unquenchable exactly it's always super
important to be specific when it comes
to fears because if you're not specific
about the things that you're afraid of
you will end up with anxiety anxiety is
always free-floating is this the feeling
of constant fear that you have and you
cannot Escape it
the seventh seal is a movie about a
chess game with death well not only
about that but yeah actually that's
funny what you said it's from mingmar uh
Bergman it's one one of them my favorite
filmmakers
and the seventh seal is uh one of my
favorite movies
kalianka hey
so actually it's very interesting to
since you mentioned it let's let's
what's the uh the scene
uh seventh
SEO uh death chess
so it's uh this is the Swedish movie and
it's one of the most
you know it's a legendary movie one of
the most important movies of all time
there's this guy the the hero and he
encounters death
yeah I did yeah you did
Incorporated
a great Cinema
foreign
[Music]
they already
fixed
do you do you guys play Chess By the way
does anyone enjoy playing chess
yeah that's the scene but I don't
remember what happens next I don't know
if you wins or not uh the seventh seal
convention to death scene
anyway
um
he wins okay
yeah guys like what's this movie the the
seventh seal it's so good so good really
verse that is individuated human life
along with the unremitting oscillation
between pain and boredom yeah I mean
that's anxiety if you really think about
it it's like the fact that
we are individuals in a scary world and
we have so much responsibility some
sometimes this responsibility becomes
unbearable and but at the same time we
need to oscillate between pain and
boredom and you know if you think about
it like that's what life is sometimes
you're bored sometimes you're excited
sometimes you're in pain and this is
this constant oscillation between pain
and boredom this creates even more
anxiety you know
Memento Mori is inescapable but it can
also lead to the emancipation of the
spirit slow the Mind down because the
fear is about projections of future
events narrow your perception to a
singular point of focus a singular point
of focus that is now
exactly a singular point of focus that
is now
okay that was nice I really like this
video uh you can always find it on my
channel
now let's move on to the next video so I
found this video by The Economist I
don't really Follow The Economist I
think it's a nice magazine but I don't
really follow it but I I watched it the
other day and I think it's uh it's very
good like seven years ago but there are
a lot of topics that they touch upon and
I think we can we can discuss it
um in depth
it is the most fundamental experience of
all defining our waking moments and
giving rise to all that we think and
feel
without Consciousness we have no way of
proving we or anything else exists
and yet what it is and why we have it
remain a mystery that some of the
greatest Minds have been unable to solve
[Music]
the only way I know I exist is because
I'm conscious I wake up in the dark of a
hotel room I'm discombobulated because
I'm jet lagged I have no idea where I am
who I am and what country I am this guy
is definitely definitely
um
German or or Israeli what do you guys
think Christopher
German American okay are there any
Germans in the chat
yet I know I exist because I see
something
rapid advances in our understanding of
how the brain works might one day allow
us to pinpoint the parts of the brain
that generate consciousness
but will something as objective as
science be able to explain what it feels
like to be us
Consciousness by its nature is private
it's subjective I know about my
Consciousness from the first person
point of view other people don't know
about my Consciousness very indirectly
philosophers have been trying to answer
some of these questions for millennia
in the past couple of centuries
scientists have joined them
debate can be fierce
in fact some Scholars reckon the puzzle
of Consciousness is something the human
mind is incapable of solving
I think that's
exactly like it's insane if you if you
think about it that we are aware of our
own existence constantly you know like
our brains are inside of us call and we
we see things and we perceive and we
know we are aware of that and we're the
only animal that can do that it's insane
and uh we don't really know how
Consciousness emerged but there is this
great hypothesis and when we finish this
video we're gonna go to the to this
hypothesis about how Consciousness
emerged not how it immersed sorry like
how how humans advance so fast in terms
of uh Consciousness not just wrong I
think it's it's uh culpably wrong it
isn't impossible at all it's just that
we have to buckle down and do it
is something the human mind is incapable
of solving
I think that's
not just wrong I think it's it's uh
culpably wrong it isn't impossible at
all it's just that we have to buckle
down and do it
one thing that both disciplines can
agree on is that Consciousness arises in
the brain
made up of roughly 85 billion neurons
and other supporting cells about which
we know little the brain consumes almost
20 percent of our energy despite
comprising just two percent of our Mass
every so often I get kind of interested
in astronomy and cosmology because you
look out there and you think oh gosh
this is amazing you know it's almost
Limitless but then I turn around and I
kind of introspectively think about the
brain and it's kind of like a universe
within we're a long ways of
understanding how it works but if we
could get down to figuring out how a
neuron works
by God then we could do it at two
neurons and then four neurons and then
four million neurons and then 100
million
helped by development and imaging partly
pioneered by Dr Reichel and his team
scientists can study in some detail the
two enormous folded sheets of outer
brain called the cerebral cortex
this plays a crucial role in higher
brain functions like memory perception
thought and language and I have two of
them in my left and right and and it's
part of this sheet that gives rise to
Consciousness the sheet also give rise
to intelligence and reasoning and all
the other things that we hold dear but
the what the human brain in the human
mind Christoph [__] wants to come up
with a satisfactory scientific theory of
Consciousness before he dies
science wants to explain everything if
if science fails to explain the central
fact of my existence
I would say then it's a it's it's a
failure
in order to gain a better understanding
of how parts of the brain work
scientists often look at bits of it bold
bold bold the way he thinks and that's
how most scientists like should think
they're broken
there is a little part of the brain
called the cerebellum which is at the
back of my brain
if I lose it I will be unable to let's
say to dance or be a rock climber and I
have difficulty moving my speech becomes
slurred but my Consciousness will not be
impaired
on the flip side it seems that some
parts of the brain may be essential for
consciousness
identifying these so-called neural
correlates of Consciousness would help
pin down what is happening what might
the NCC the neural correlative
Consciousness be like assuming that it
is that it's an emergent and a
neuroscientific process and let me say
straight away that we don't know what
it's like before his death in 2004
Francis Crick the co-discoverer of the
structure of DNA worked with Dr Koch on
something they termed The Binding
problem
put simply The Binding problem asks how
the brain integrates different bits of
information it gets both sensory and
internal into our conscious experience
in real life the brain is terribly good
and puts everything together the
movement
the shape and and the color
the usual way of saying The Binding
problem is if you have a red square and
a green triangle how is it that you
don't have see it as the get the colors
mixed up with the shapes that's
basically the problem
because our experience of Consciousness
is derived from the data we get from
lots of different systems the visual and
motor being just two the two men looked
at a part of the brain that is connected
to all these regions
they were especially interested in the
classroom a thin sheet of nerve cells
that sits at the bottom of the cerebral
cortex in each hemisphere of the brain
because testing the clostrum in a live
human brain is invasive and risky no
formal experiments have been done but
one happened accidentally last year when
a neurologist trying to understand the
source of his patient's epilepsy
implanted electrodes near her clostra
when he switched the current on she lost
Consciousness as soon as he switched it
off she regained it
no one knows why we have Consciousness
it's one of the big Mysteries why did
Evolution bother putting Consciousness
in how did Evolution put Consciousness
in why couldn't we have done everything
that we do with a set of objective
mechanisms and no first person
subjective experience of the world uh
it's one of the biggest questions in
philosophy in science just as the
processes of Consciousness remain a
mystery so does its purpose is it a high
level summary the brain generates to
help us plan for what comes next a
clever way of Designing our brains to
make us more Adept at being social
neither both
one evolutionary explanation for why we
have Consciousness suggested an animal
capable of modeling the behavior of
another can anticipate it to its
Advantage the surprising thing is that
so few animals actually have this
ability humans have it so I have a very
good idea of what you're going to do and
when you're going to do it and why
you're going to do it and children
starting at maybe around three years old
get that Janet Metcalf studies something
called the theory
M83 my tears are becoming a c okay let's
finish the video first then maybe of
mind uh theory of mind is actually
misnomer the way we test it is whether a
person or an animal
can give evidence that they can get into
the other person's shoes or the other
person's mind and see the world from
that person's perspective
now the the test of it is often not just
can you see from the Viewpoint of the
other person but could you see that
someone has a different Viewpoint from
your own
the theory of Mind might provide one way
of working out if animals other than
humans are conscious the only species
that we're absolutely sure has theory of
mind is human
and maybe humans older than roughly
three years old
it's very controversial whether any
other animals have it they're arguing
about whether chimps have theory of mind
or not
before we can have a theory of them it's
insane right it's insane that we are the
only creature that can actually bonded
its own existence and like what happens
it's impossible for us to understand how
it feels not to do so so you're like
you're going about your life and you're
just what
you're just experiencing you're just
like attracted by smells and desires and
feelings and whatever process happens
inside of you and you cannot like
analyze that it's impossible for me to
Fathom all right we must recognize
ourselves for decades scientists have
used something called the Rouge test to
see whether animals do just that
human babies do from about 18 months old
chimpanzees presented with mirrors soon
use them to groom themselves much as we
do elephants dolphins and magpies also
can respond to mirrors in ways that
suggest self-recognition
um the problem with the Rouge test that
the animal self recognition doesn't mean
that
um that you know the creature is
actually conscious I don't think so
researchers
always raise is that maybe it's just
body knowledge that it's not mind
knowledge
so it was interpreted as the animal
knowing that they have a mind and theory
of Mind as we normally think about it is
related to another person not to the
self but presumably you have to know
that you have a mind before you project
that same capability onto someone else
identifying the neural correlates of
empathy is lovely yeah I think empathy
is the Bedrock of
um
of communication and the Bedrock of
um social interactions but I don't know
if
yeah it's strongly related to
Consciousness you cannot have conscious
Consciousness without empathy for sure
it's the body not the awareness yeah
yeah that's what I think
self-recognition in animals would be a
hard task but if we were able to do it
comparative studies would be possible
that would be hugely valuable
[Music]
science is edging closer to
understanding what parts of the brain
might be involved in generating
conscious experience by some estimates
we may not be far away from an
empirically sound Theory Of
Consciousness and how it evolved
but could a physical Theory ever
satisfactorily address what it is that
people are feeling when they are
conscious
David Chalmers calls Consciousness the
hard problem a Deft description yeah uh
that the the hard problem
um somehow is discussed about the heart
heart problem a lot and his
um
he's mentioning this essay
is this essay by David Chalmers uh
uh what how does it feel to be bad I
think let's see what he says here and
for something that is hard to explain
and hard to solve the methods of science
right now are great for explaining
objective processes and objective
functions so when it comes even to
explaining things like the behavior of
an organism you can tell some story
about a bit of the brain a neural
process or a computer-like process in
the brain that makes us behave a certain
way but the problem of Consciousness
what we call the hard problem of
Consciousness which is explaining how
you get subjective experience from the
brain is not that kind of question
with David David Chalmers
yeah that's the one is there anything it
is like to be a bat
oh no
that's not PMS hacker I don't know that
Dave Chalmers on being a bat
David Chalmers thinks that hard problem
is really hard yeah
it is uh uh yeah
[Music]
I'm more and more confused what it was
made with conscious we just have a more
complex set to express conscious in my
opinion no no no like uh it's it's the
fact that we are aware of our own
existence like now I'm talking to you
and I know that I'm talking to you and
this is not like a mechanical process
this is like I'm aware of that and so
there's no other creature that can do
that I mean like a dog can bark but he's
just like a an instinctive mechanism
it's not like the the dog knows that
it's doing that and it can form like a
more
complicated set of
um I don't know processes that can lead
to something more elaborate
it's not a question about how we behave
it's a question about you know what it's
like about how it feels from the inside
and looks like you can explain all those
objective mechanisms and objective
processes and you still won't have
answered the hard problem which is why
is it that all that functioning is
accompanied by consciousness
the hard problem divides philosophers
and scientists alike
some philosophers argue that
Consciousness can be explained far more
simply
[Music]
a lot of puzzles no Mysteries
we're going to understand it from the
bottom up and from the top down
I have no doubt about that
Daniel Dennett argues that Consciousness
is nothing more than a cognitive
illusion that science will into course
explain
our brains have been designed by
Evolution and then redesigned by this
guy who's talking Daniel
he's a great
I think he's a he's a philosopher and he
had an amazing
um he has an amazing Ted talk so we're
going to watch it after we watch the
stone day hypothesis
by cultural Evolution to give us
a user-friendly
system of things in the world that we
deal with so the user-friendly world
that we live in the Manifest image is a
sort of
friendly user illusion in the same way
that the desktop of your laptop is a
user illusion it simplifies and it
distorts in helpful ways for most
purposes if you really want to know
what's going on you have to go backstage
and the same thing is true about the
brain and Consciousness
so recently we didn't have very good
tools for doing it my brain was just off
limits as off limits as
distant galaxies
we're now developing the tools for
non-invasively studying the brain
and we're now developing the
computational
ideas and models so that we can
understand how a brain can
non-muraciously deal with information
and refine it and uncover the semantics
of the world or outside
and inside
so we're now we now have the toolkit
and it's taken this long to develop it
now we just have to use the tools
yeah I mean they didn't say perhaps but
for the time being the puzzle of
Consciousness continues to pose more
questions than it does answers
yet another philosopher protagoras of
abdera proclaimed that man is the
measure of all things
until the problem of Consciousness is
solved though that might better be
phrased the measure of all things but
himself
a measure of all things but himself yeah
when you stay humble I mean this video
didn't say anything like you didn't say
nothing new
okay thank you so much Economist for the
insight
killer towards this
where is it plus damage okay
this guy is uh is a genius he's he used
to be a very close friend of Dennis
McKenna and teles McKenna
um he came up with the Dennis McKenna is
like this guy here oh okay you can't see
anyway uh let's listen to him he
developed this hypothesis called the
stoned ape Theory
and uh you're gonna find out what's
going on here right now it's very
interesting very interesting
Terence and Dennis both actually have
if and this goes into actually the
evolution of human consciousness and
Terence McKenna was a good friend of
mine I loved Terence I especially loved
him the last five years of his life
because he made fun of himself so much
Terence people took Terence way too
seriously in many levels but as his
brother Dennis which I think has been on
your show a couple times yeah then this
is a great guy great Ally great
scientist but you know Dennis said even
if 10 of what Terence said was true is
is freaking amazing is and Terence and
Dennis both came up with it staying
stoned a theory now it's not a theory
it's a hypothesis a hypothesis is
speculative but cannot necessarily be as
not yet proven a theory is a hypothesis
that has been tested and proven with
facts so I disagree with them and saying
it's not a theory it's a hypothesis okay
interesting I didn't know that this is a
difference between a hypothesis and a
theory like maybe he's making that up
because essentially hypothesis and
theory is the same thing thing they're
both
no no no he's right because hypothesis
means a hypothesis is a Greek word which
means like when you assume uh theory is
like when you
think about something a theory is
something that you can actually prove
yeah that's true the hypothesis the
stone
of the stone Dave which I think you've
alluded to before is that with climate
change and as a Savannah's increase in
our primary ancestors came out of the
out of the forest canopies they're
they're tracking across the Savannah and
if you're a hunter what do you look you
look for footsteps let me look for Scott
uh and the most significant fleshy
mushroom going out of poop in in Africa
hippopotamus elephants you know deer
Antelope Etc
um is Las Vegas it's a very large
mushroom you're hungry you're with your
clan
you consume it
and then 20 minutes later you're you are
catapulted in this extraordinary
experience psilocybin substitutes a
serotonin becomes a better
neurotransmitter activates neurogenesis
it causes new neurons to form new
Pathways of knowledge so that's the
stone date hypothesis and it speaks to a
mystery that the human brain basically
the brain cavity doubled in size in
about two million years some people
today's less is two less than 200 000.
Homo sapiens around 200 000 years Homo
sapiens arrive uh 200 000 to 300 000
years ago that's a big gap right it's a
big gap well the science is like that so
you want you know to be scientifically
accurate here I need to show the the
extreme margins of what's been estimated
so if we accept two million years that
the and it's been shown the fossil
record this is true the oldest Homo
sapiens fossils are 300 000 years old
now
um but we have a suddenly doubling of
the human brain
um and with that our language centers
increased our ability to prognosticate
to plan
um and
so what he said is that it double in
size within the span of 200 000 years
that's insane right and there
um
they have this hypothesis that because
the like the first Homo sapiens
um were situated in central Africa and
there were a lot of psychedelic
mushrooms there these people they
consume the mushrooms and because you
know whenever you consume the mushroom
like a psychedelic mushroom you have
it's like a delicate experience and this
like opens up your mind and whatnot and
you become more self-aware more
enlightened uh they think that they did
that and they kept doing that on a
regular basis so that's why the the
human brain doubly doubled uh in size
within such a short time period it's
crazy
there's no explanation for this uh
currently and
even though we may not be able to prove
it I asked people to suspend their
disability for a second now think of
this
our primate ancestors are going across
the Savannah the Injustice mushrooms as
a clan
massive input for anyone who's eaten
these mushrooms huge amounts of data is
coming in fractal patterns geometrical
you know Landscapes occur
you have empathy uh you have greater
imaginary or or primitive ancestors
getting higher on mushrooms psychedelic
mushrooms
empathy encourage you're fighting a
saber-toothed tiger you know one day
you're you have a fear of it we know now
from neurogenesis and the extension of
the fear response that has been
clinically proven psilocybin allows you
to reset and have different neurological
Pathways to respond to fear overcoming
the fear of condition response
potentially PTSD and there's a lot of
research on this currently so but this
wouldn't happen one time with one
hominid
I saw this in a psychedelic experience
with Ayahuasca so an ape looking
creature mounting on mushrooms that's
interesting Jaguars also Manchester
Vines I don't know what a Yaga Vine is I
think I'm pronouncing correctly
um I had a piece yesterday with a long
walk nice man
um but that's interesting you know
um I don't know about Ayahuasca but I
think that when it comes to mushrooms
I've heard that a mushroom when you
consume a mushroom and psychedelic
mushroom you're actually doing
uh you're having the the experience that
the mushroom mushroom wants you to have
so the mushroom is trying to lead you
somewhere and based on you know on your
uh genetic makeup you you decide how to
use this experience so yeah
um
but it's interesting that you had this
uh experience with ayahuasca
now
um the thing with Ayahuasca is like I
don't know I had an another friend of
mine for example had another experience
with Ayahuasca and he said that he had
he he lived like during his trip I don't
know how many hours like four or five
hours he lived the life of an of a male
elk you know in the um somewhere in
Canada and then he like at the beginning
of the trip he he was born you know as
an elk and then uh at the at the end of
the trip he actually died so we can you
can see many things but it's very
interesting that you say that they're
called children because they're very
playful okay nice nice
group what happened two times ten times
it happened millions and millions and
millions and millions of times over
millions and millions of years this
leads to what I think is called uh this
should be called epigenetic neurogenesis
we know that there's a regeneration of
neuron yeah but I mean
if they keep kept consuming them like
for years and years and they I think
they they would have like the the our
brain would eventually become like
I don't know accustomed to
consuming this kind of substances and
that means that the current version of
of homo sapiens like us humans wouldn't
have like a crazy trip whenever we we
eat a psychedelic uh substances so
this is kind of uh controversial but
whatever
we know that substitutes the serotonin
it opens the floodgates of the senses
you have a lot more data coming in and
we know that it has the extinction of
the fear response so if you're the
leader of your clan you've had this
traumatic event either war or cataclysm
from earthquakes whatever the case may
be or encounter a saber-toothed tiger
whatever if you're the leader of that
Clan
and you can overcome your fear response
you have courage
and you have empathy
those are leadership skills
I think these people can take note of it
people like to follow leaders who are
courageous and yet kind
who they can trust they'll have their
best interests in mind so I think this
propelled
how's your buttons getting high
translated into genetic changes
over millions of years probably it
affects your DNA at some point I think
we would probably just figure out how to
synthesize more powerful substances to
ingest probably yeah
I think it's a lot it's a very good
explanation it's an unprovable
hypothesis
but now we're at a junction and for the
net and we're ready for the next Quantum
Leap in human consciousness I think
psilocybin should be looked upon as a
nootropic vitamin leap in human
consciousness and there's a huge amount
of interest in this Johns Hopkins
universities you probably well know New
York University UCLA elsewhere in Europe
there's major clinical studies that have
been conducted in the past two years
showing exactly what I'm saying about
overcoming fear response neurogenesis
overcoming PTSD this is now medically
quite seriously considered and something
that I think that we should explore
under controlled settings I'm not into
partying with Souls Ivan mushrooms damn
damn
[Laughter]
is going to be here in an hour and a
half and he's the creator of shroom Fest
he's going to be very upset with your
idea that you shouldn't party with it
what
happened
uh
uh okay
it's like look at this
I was gonna say mushrooms can help save
the world it's actually a great uh
documentary on Netflix with Paul stamets
uh stamets
um
Netflix
fantastic
fungi
this is like
so good my mission is to discover the
language of Nature and I believe nature
is intelligent
there is a world under the Earth
full of magic and mystery
and holds the consciousness of Nature's
have you guys ever tried by the way have
you guys ever tried like uh magic
mushrooms I'm not gonna tell anyone it's
gonna stay between us
all living things
[Music]
foreign
s they can heal you they can feed you
they can kill you many times
I cannot say about myself
vegetables not like a animal but it's
somewhere in between they support life
they convert life as you're walking
there's about 300 miles of fungi under
every footstep that you take and that's
right all over the world
the bulk of the organism is growing
underground and it's composed of these
long threads called a mycelium almost
everyone knows about the computer
internet the mycelium shares the same
network design
it's
okay nice good to know and how did it
like how did it affect you do you feel
that it changed your perception did you
do you feel that you sow things that
helped you understand reality better or
um perceive reality in a different way
or what what did what did you see like
let me know because I had a discussion
with many people who tried mushrooms and
uh
um
they both sing great things very
interesting things
I take them when I need to solve a
problem solve a problem what does that
even mean
depends a lot of what mushrooms I'm a
solely supporter of natural medicines
yeah me too me too
amazing what we don't know about
mushrooms they really are a frontier of
knowledge you can filter water you can
create medicinal compounds almost on
demand they have incredible capacity
water this guy by the way Michael Poland
he wrote this book uh
um
what's the book how to change your mind
such a good book guys that's a good book
how to change your mind he talks about
you know
psychedelics and uh
how
he's now 65 I think and it's the first
time he tried psychedelics like with um
someone who is uh
you know who's taking care of him at the
same time like micro dosing not micro
dosing like taking small doses mainly
but he had his he wrote all his
experiences in the in the book and it's
a great book like great read he's a
journalist actually but he's also a
great writer
about mushrooms they really are a
frontier of knowledge you can filter
water
this was after taking Ayahuasca many
times so for me mushrooms feel like a
lighter Ayahuasca solve a problem get
clarity between two opposing
perspectives well yeah but what what are
the two opposing perspectives this is
like are you talking about your
um Earthly basic self and your higher
self that's what you mean uh made myself
aware of my own body and ego and how
they interact with each other okay
that's nice I realize the Oneness of
Consciousness and it made me a lot more
compassionate yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's true you you have a lot of
empathy when you're on psychedelics and
I think that
uh
uh you start to make sense of of of many
things that matter and many things that
don't matter
and also I think you you start to
believe in the idea of parallel
universes I I don't know if any of you
had like an experience with parallel
universes while on psychedelics it's
interesting
to discuss that
gaining New Perspective from which was
not previously seen okay nice I was just
laughing during the trip one hour later
I threw up before puking it was pure
Bliss
yeah yeah it's insane it's insane I
think
a lot of people throw up it's just like
your body is reacting it's too much for
your body so you need like just to throw
up so you can you know kind of reboot I
think
you can create medicinal compounds
almost on demand they have incredible
capacity to make things change very
quickly so I am super hopeful
it's crazy you guys like that are
mushrooms everywhere everywhere like
that's why actually
um that's that's why food goes bad
because when it goes food goes moldy is
because there is like mushrooms like in
the small particles of mushrooms in the
in the air in the environment and they
land on your food and they just start to
grow there's nothing you can do about it
that's why food goes bad with time delic
members of the Mushroom Kingdom are
fascinating
I have been a guide for around 350
psilocybin sessions the most
um I started this journey to heal from
trauma so I took them ceremonially for
five years okay I felt the end of The
Five-Year Journey my life was fully
transformed more space to contemplate
and less Reactions
where do you where do you live now
that's very interesting because
I used to live in Bali in Indonesia and
whenever I was in and now I'm in Athens
in Greece right I moved
um and I feel that whenever I'm I'm in a
place that is close to Nature let's say
an island or
there is a lot of beautiful nature
nearby I feel more enlightened I feel
more
um
present and the moment I go somewhere
where it's like the city is full of
distractions you know like a lot of cars
like bad Aesthetics a lot of people a
lot of noise I lose that I lose like I
become less enlightened enlightened
immediately and
um this kind of
affects you know my my psyche affects my
perception constantly
mushroom spores could travel through
space
I was psychedelics basically do is strip
things to their bare minimum when no
filters are applied to values and
beliefs you can recall it and later
repeat use this kind of New Perspective
no I agree with that so I'll describe
our connection to the universe I live in
America now I used to live in Costa Rica
I did Ayahuasca or Ecuador Colombia and
Costa Rica but yeah okay but where in
America because America is huge like ah
because it's different to live you know
in the mountains of Colorado and
different to live in the center of New
York glorious part was that it made me
feel more comfortable with living
because you're not afraid of dying we
need to have a paradigm I'm in the
mountains of Montana USA how is it there
how's it
and our Consciousness what will it take
to achieve that
we can heal the planet
we can build the future
in our world is fantastic
[Music]
um Michael Poland
hmm
yes what's this one this one is a good
one do you are you aware of
um the book The immortality Keith yeah
Brian Murray's book fascinating
fascinating and he's found you know he's
writing about evidence of very early use
I would never do psychedelics in the
city
yeah I feel yeah
set and setting is more important than a
journey itself 100 100 I have friends
here in Athens who are doing like uh
psychedelics they they go to Apartments
outside of the city but still doesn't
feel the same I don't know I don't know
it doesn't feel you know alluring
in the old world of psychedelic
compounds uh ergot which is the fungus
from which LSD is derived was found in
some communion cups right in Spain yeah
that's kind of wild wild and the idea
that the Eucharist may have involved uh
psychedelic there was also cannabis
found in some Jewish sites from that
period
and I've always wondered about wine and
Greece you know that they would talk
about these wild dionysian Rebels and
then they drank wine out of glasses like
this big right they had to be something
else oh for sure and also did you know
wine back then at a very low alcohol
content I didn't know that yeah
how do you know that Joe to suspect that
uh they're spiking it they were spiking
it with something we don't know what I
mean okay ancient Greeks were spiking
the wine with psychedelics why not and
we don't know how to how you would use
airgot because aragot can also give you
gangrene really oh yeah it wouldn't take
it orally it'll give you a game I don't
know well I don't know how else you take
it but what do you see it's air God
because aragot can also give you
gangrene what's that
what is that you guys know what he means
ergot is that what do you mean it's very
good fungi
first I grew I don't know
really oh yeah it wouldn't take it
orally I don't know I well I don't know
how else you take it but people so
ergotism was this disease people got
when they ate you know in a wet year the
Rye crop would get all this aragot on it
but people
they were actually watering down
watering the water down you mean the
wine
okay
airgot
that's the one right that's what he
means our God
they're good is in their gut fungi
refers to a group of fungi and the
genius
whatever
psychoactive
okay
that was okay
desperate they would still make bread
from it and it would make people uh kind
of crazy well they think that that is
the Salem Rich trial right
and that you have these outbreaks of
what was called witchcraft which was
just people having visions and tripping
tripping basically yeah and so and their
episodes all through European history of
these outbreaks Saint Vitus deangel is
another term that was used for this and
um and those outbreaks coincide with
core samples that show like particularly
yeah and especially with years where
when you've got lots of fungus and um
but the other effect you can get from
eating this stuff is is gangrene so if
it was consumed as a drug it was
processed in some way to make it safe
and the elusian Mysteries that Brian
talks about in that book too which was
this right in Greece that went on for
thousands of years in every great Greek
writer politician participated in this
there was a potion that they would take
called Kiki on everyone that's where
they got the last of us from uh yeah
yeah like supposedly in The Last of Us
they there is a there is a mushroom like
uh that
um has evolved to such a degree that can
affect human brain just by you know like
um it's so easy to transmit between
human beings and uh uh it's just like
changes the the the the the shape of
your brain and you become like uh this
creature is not necessarily like a
zombie or an undead but this this weird
creature is like the the the the
mushroom has taken over and after we
finish that we're gonna what's the the
intro of uh love us where there's this
scientists discussing that actually
most of us opening scene
yeah that's the one
let's just finish that first
sworn to secrecy so no one talked about
that actually let's wrote it because
someone uh I wanna
foreign
look up the
SE Mysteries that he's talking about
so that's the last of us guys like if
you haven't watched it's a really good
TV show and
um and that's your biggest word maybe
some of you have also played the game
it's really good games something similar
to it
because of air travel
ing cordyceps yeah
it's a new virus in Madagascar say it
could be in Chicago within a matter of
weeks and we end up with a global
pandemic and meaning all the whole world
becomes sickle at once hmm
and Dr Newman you're also an
epidemiologist I presume a prospect of a
viral pandemic keeps you up at night as
well no no no all right well that's our
show no mankind has been at war with the
virus from the start sometimes millions
of people die as in an actual War but in
the end we always win but you uh just to
be clear you you do think microorganisms
pose a threat or in the most dire terms
bacteria no you like saying no yes
not bacteria not viruses so fungus
yes that's the usual response fungi seem
harmless enough many species know
otherwise because there are some fungi
who seek not to kill but to control let
me ask you where do we get fungi fungir
fungi how do you pronounce it I'm
butchering it every time
fungi fungi why are you seeing fungi but
it doesn't really matter to me
LSD from where do you get it from it
comes from ergot singular fungi
so it's a fungi uh okay a singular is
fungi and now singular singular singular
is fungus
it's fungus
singular fungi plural right
yeah exactly it's fungi or fungi
maybe it's UK
whatever it's not so important
psilocybin also a fungus viruses can
make us ill but fungi can alter our very
Minds there's a fungus that infects
insects gets inside an ant for example
travels through its circulatory system
to the ant's brain and then floods it
with hallucinogens thus bending the ants
mind to its will fungus starts to direct
the ant's Behavior telling it where to
go what to do like a puppeteer with a
marionette and it gets worse the fungus
needs food to live so it begins to
devour its host from within replacing
the ants flesh with its own but it
doesn't let its victim die no it it
keeps its puppet Alive by preventing
decomposition how where do we get
penicillin from fungus oh and you start
to show on Heist you're in distress
fungal infection of this kind is real
but not in humans true fungi cannot
survive if its host's internal
temperature is over 94 degrees and
currently there are no reasons for fungi
to evolve to be able to withstand higher
temperatures but what if that were to
change what if
slightly warmer
wow yeah yeah so this is like
subtle criticism on global warming as
well
there is reason to evolve one gene
mutates
global warming that temperature will
rise and this uh any one of them could
become capable of borrowing into our
brains and taking control not of
millions of us but billions of us yeah
billions of puppets with poisoned Minds
permanently fixed on one unified
every last human alive by any means
necessary and there are no treatments
for this no preventatives no cures they
don't exist it's not even possible to
make them
so if that happens
we lose
okay
we'll be back
we lose
your politician participated in this
there was a potion that they would take
called the kikion everyone was sworn to
secrecy so no one talked about this but
they would take this potion and Coop
down right I don't know my Greek is
shitty
k-y-k-e-o-n and they would um what's
that
it's an ancient Greek drink of various
descriptions some were made mainly water
barley and natural curing substances
were made with wine and grated cheese
and so widely believed that kikyon
usually refers to psychoactive companion
Brew
okay
uh go to the underworld and visit with
their ancestors and have these visions
and it kind of makes sense when you
think of like Plato's idea that there's
an unseen realm right next to this one
yeah where the real table is you know I
guess it's just the secondary table
um so but how do we prove these things
you know
um the the work these archaeologists are
doing interesting work what he said
about Plato you know he's discussing the
the the the
um the world of Shadows
um
it's this video I'm talking about it
here
where is it right here the allegory of
the cave
uh and there's going to be a new
Institute at Harvard working on some of
these questions yeah it is all sparked
by Brian's work and Brian's appearance
on this podcast in fact oh really let's
initiated these discussions because
they've realized like when when you hear
him talk about it and you understand the
amount of research this guy's done for
over a decade pursuing this and it's a
really it was a big risk because until
they found the samples that indicated
there was ergot inside these vessels
they really didn't know if this was
speculative is this all horseshit you
know they didn't know and now they do
know it's it's yeah it all makes sense
right if anybody who's ever done a
psychedelic drug it makes sense I you
know look I think psychedelics have had
a very profound effect on cultural
evolution in many many ways
um the The Encounter of these molecules
with a certain mind produces memes new
ideas metaphors theories and visions
that sometimes not always
um ends up changing everything
um you know 99 of the things people
inside people have on psychedelics are
probably not that valuable you know I
mean they may be personally useful you
know Love is Everything whatever it is
but every now and then in a certain mind
uh there's an idea and it might be a
vision of an after World it might be the
idea of an unseen other world a Beyond
um and then that person tells that story
and suddenly this enters culture yeah
somebody had a vision they went up on a
mountain and they saw God
it's a very plausible explanation for
how religion might get started it
completely makes sense to me and that's
crazy that's crazy that's so accurate
actually it could be true like
if you think about it psychedelics
helped us
um
accelerate the process of Consciousness
to become more conscious
but also it could be possible that it's
because of psychedelics that we have
religions nowadays
fact wasn't there no no nowadays but
like that's how we also discovered the
notion of religion that these creatures
speak to us while we're high and we
don't know what they are so we find a
um we try to come up with an explanation
and we say like this is a divine
creature that is speaking to me so it's
probably God speaking to me
it's been some work at the one of the
universities in Israel where they were
they're trying to connect the uh acacia
tree with the burning bush that Moses
saw because the acacia tree apparently
is rich in DMT and they're trying to
their their connection they're making is
the burning bush being God was consuming
smoked DMT and that they were having
this Vision that Moses was has I mean it
makes sense if you're if you're
translating things from ancient Hebrew
to Latin to Greek to whatever the [__]
they're doing you're gonna lose a lot of
whatever they're trying to say and
especially now know what's a metaphor
and what's literal exactly exactly and
that's what they think that's
fascinating I haven't heard about that I
have to follow up on that so I'm very
interested in the role that psychedelics
have played and it's true in science too
right I mean we just took a PCR test I
think uh you know covet test and who
invented PCR a scientist named Carrie
mollus who got the idea
um on an LST
yeah that's what I was going to say was
high on mushrooms or something but
northern California yeah and he's and
he's talked about it and he said LSD
allowed me to sit on the molecule and
watch and see what was going on and so
that Encounter of that molecule with
that mind gave us this amazing tool that
all of genetics to
if you lose the Psychedelic experience
you take things literally and lose the
wisdom of the experience I like that
that's so true that's so true it's like
you limit yourself to a very basic uh
mode of uh thing thinking and
experiencing the world around you yeah
we took a rapid antigen test by the way
oh okay all right
yeah he's spoken out about that he just
it's it's not what it's for it shouldn't
be used in that regard interesting yeah
but anyway but he found it again yeah
figured it out and there's you know
there's there are many stories through
history I mean I think you know the
human imagination has a natural history
right it has to ever okay since we are
uh discussing this topic
um let's watch this video this guy so
many things that Terence
uh Hamilton Morris I don't know if you
guys know him
he's um he's an American journalist uh
uh he used to work for vice I don't know
what he does anymore
but he had this TV show advice called
Hamilton's Pharma
that's how you pronounce it
pharmacopoeia pharmacopoeia
um yeah really good really good TV show
see if there's we can watch something
here
getting high on the perfect kind of
setting okay yeah but that's not so
interesting that he goes on uh on some
weird places and and he's tipping
hallucinogenic frogs this is a good
episode
let's just watch this first and when we
can watch it later
I said it's both true and untrue I think
it's untrue in a literal sense but very
true in a poetic sense because the
by the way this stream tonight is going
to be around two hours like maybe two
and a half hours
so we have like one one hour left
historical cultural context of a drug is
part of what you bring to that drug
experience the molecule does not contain
information but as you can see the the
the the stream is very like Dynamic very
flexible so we can jump from one topic
to the other but all the topics are
somehow connected to the human
experience and I think they're very
interesting and although I have like so
many videos like you're prepared for you
uh it's it's it's nice to you know even
even though we we we we lose track of
what we were talking about in the
beginning
now we're focusing on a very specific
topic that um affects all of us on a
very deep level so it's it's nice that
we are discussing psychedelics that
wasn't part of my plan for today but I'm
really enjoying it
in molecule does not bring an experience
to you that is something that is
generated in your brain by your
Consciousness and by the way uh like uh
do you guys know what a DMT is like do
have you ever uh tried DMT uh dmts like
also psychedelic you smoke it I've never
tried it before but supposedly uh it's
DMT is it's called the god molecule so
you have like a very a near-death
experience when you smoke that and you
cut a pull to yourself to the outer
space and then you see yourself like the
image of yourself on Earth and you just
lose touch with reality but you have
like crazy encounters with crazy
creatures you know stuff like that
so if you have a new substance that has
no cultural associations then maybe it
was like that so you don't have
expectations you don't have expectations
right that's a big part of it isn't it
it's a huge part of it yeah yeah I mean
I I made a piece in the new season of my
show about
um
5meo DMT containing toad Venom
um and there's a big controversy in the
toad Venom Community which believe it or
not is a community and they are purists
are they friends
I had both it's what allows us to dream
okay eopia files
oh definitely not no no they don't like
the opio files so what is the Venom
Community think they think that this
venom has some spiritual component
derived from its association with the
toad that makes it better than synthetic
five Amino DMT now I've analyzed several
samples of toad Venom and before 5 Amino
DMT was made illegal in the United
States and in terms of what you find if
you you know inject it into a mass
spectrometer five meodmt is the only
psychedelic that's present in some
samples there might be Trace quantities
of another psychedelic called buffotonin
but it's a minuscule amount of a less
potent molecule so predominantly you
have five Amino DMT which is likely the
strongest naturally occurring
serotonergic psychedelic and
for conservation purposes it's necessary
that people stop milking toads because
it's become too popular Mike Tyson's
talking about it all the
five favorite museum T was 14 minutes
but it was so intense it took me a few
weeks to do the internal one okay never
tried it so was there is a difference
between five Emil DMT and DMT I I don't
get it thrilled to have Coachella Sky
gazer nice to have you here
until it connected yeah it's all
connected iOS they just DMT and enter
the bloodstream okay
I am I I made I mean and then it's like
it sounds ridiculous like Mike Tyson
could have an effect on
um conservation but if a celebrity says
they like something that can have a
tangible effect on the environment I
know people who have toads
for that very reason because Mike Tyson
talked about those toads now they have
toads and they milk these toads oh yeah
I mean me too I I talked with a
billionaire who flew a private jet full
of toads too
Greece to Greece to create a private
toad Sanctuary
wow how many toads you got and the
photos it didn't look like that many it
didn't look like a jet full five Meo DMT
does not strike me as something that
you'd want to do a lot it's so
terrifying that's probably the most
terrifying experience I've ever had on
psychedelics because I cease to exist
like it's the the one drug where I feel
ah okay okay okay but what does d DMT
stand for
a dimethyltryptamine okay okay okay
Mt versus five
meal DMT
I'm not doing that right so there is
like
I'm doing something wrong here
because there are no answers to that
okay anyway
when I took it I wasn't there anymore I
I was gone until I came back like I felt
like I didn't have thoughts I don't know
about you guys like do you guys like uh
Joe Rogan I mean for me uh um
I have mixed feelings sometimes I like
him sometimes I don't sometimes I feel
that
he's he's a smart guy and the fact that
he has tried all those psychedelics like
I feel that it has allowed him to open
up his mind and that's why he's like
showing so much interest to to like
different people but I think that he he
has a problem with
um the way he understands politics and
capitalism and the way Society works and
he cannot like
um she cannot really
process information in in a very like
elaborate way and he's constantly trying
to go deep but he's just scratching the
surface when it comes to those topics
like he has like a
um he's rejecting things that where he
has a very established belief system on
like
um
when it comes to say to psychedelics or
um things uh things like martial arts
you can see him talking like he's a
different person but when it comes to
things that
he doesn't really understand but he
doesn't want to understand he changes
completely and that's like bothering me
sometimes but
he has very interesting uh guests that's
why I like listen to him sometimes and
the the form of the podcast is really
good
didn't have I I knew I knew I was
experiencing the five heavyo DMT realm
or whatever it was but I didn't there
was no context in terms of I didn't
realize I'm on my couch sitting at home
like I was gone I was gone there's no
visuals it was just this white sort of
pixelated like grayish white gone world
you know and it was terrifying because
it felt like death it was the one thing
that felt the most like oh my God like
now now I don't now I'm not here anymore
but coming back from it I think it was
very valuable
psychedelics can also reinforce your own
belief system it doesn't always open
your mind
you know what this reminds me of therapy
uh
we when we see someone that has like a
very deep psychological issue and you're
like oh you need therapy man or a try
therapy
it has happened to me many times that I
meet people who went to therapy and
instead of just like becoming aware of
their problem and
trying to you know do baby steps towards
the the the like trajectory of
actually solving the problem
um I feel that sometimes the therapist
because a lot of these people have I
don't know confidence issues what they
do is that they're trying to reinforce
their uh not their belief system uh but
sometimes their ego and uh instead like
the the person becomes even even more
egotistic than and then it was before
and
um this is something really really
interesting uh to to consider that's why
like therapy can be very tricky and uh
I know that the role of of the therapist
is not to always
provide answers like to give you like
straightforward answers but like to kind
of guide you and um make you like to ask
certain questions that can lead you
somewhere but
um a lot of times this like somewhere is
um is very wrong for uh for the
individual and maybe that's what
happened with
um Joe Rogan as well maybe he had the
wrong therapist I don't know
like as I was returning I remember
thinking so much about
so much about the the [__] way in
which I talk I remember thinking that
like God he's like so much of the way I
would communicate was not just me trying
to get my thoughts across but me trying
to say things in a way that would be
impressive or in a way that would be
flowery or you know try to make it look
like I was more intelligent than it was
or whatever but I remember like
remembering that like really clearly
like I gotta clean up the way I talk so
I'm full of [__] like thinking that as I
was like as I was trying to figure out
how I was going to describe this
experience
I was realizing as I was thinking like
God I gotta figure out how to describe
this like boy I talk like I'm full of
[__] like like so there was value in
that but
I did it a few times I think I did it
three times but it was uh terrifying
every time
like he's self-aware you see but
um
even when you are self-aware I feel that
sometimes when you recognize that you're
full of [__] sometimes when you you took
[__]
this kind of like the things that you
say even if it's [__] it's part of
your belief system and it's part of your
identity it's like such a big part of
your identity and you cannot let go
because Letting Go affects your uh your
whole like existence somehow and it's
like letting go of your existence like
it's exactly what happens during the
the Psychedelic trick like you have like
an ego death you have a very near-death
experience
and
that's why what everybody should feel
when they're about to let go of their uh
belief system it's crazy terrifying like
while you're gone like while you slip
away I remember just thinking like whoa
this is not good this is not good like
you feel like oh my God I [__] up like
I really died I really I really stopped
being here and it also makes you think
maybe this is going to the light maybe
this is what they talk about when they
talk about going to the light when you
die like maybe you're having this kind
of experience because it's really
disturbing but then pretty peaceful when
it's over like uh I felt pretty good
when it came back but the concept of
giving away all of my control of reality
like that for some reason NN DMT doesn't
scare me as much
it's a totally different drug yeah yeah
experientially chemically it's you know
silicon is closer to
DMT than 5 Mio DMT is mushrooms are
closer chemically speaking Yeah and
yeah I think that it defies description
in a different way than other
psychedelic experiences do with
something like DMT it's difficult to
describe because there is such an
abundance of imagery and thoughts and
dissociations that it's extremely
difficult to communicate that to someone
with five
Sky gazer
a lot a long but enlightening Journey
I'm really happy to hear that maybe
share some of your
um I don't know
uh top moments let's say when it comes
to this journey
udmt there's nothing and that's also
difficult to communicate that is white
out and there is an absence of
everything completely do you find it
terrifying
I have found it terrifying yes it's very
I've you know I've I had a very profound
experience with it in 2017 and I have no
real desire to use it again yeah that's
my thought too
went back there I'll go back to NN DMT
I'll go back to that oh me too because
it's just a different drug entirely and
I think that
DMT can be integrated into a normal life
much more easily than five Amino DMT
actually I I credit DMT with like sort
of I talked about the sort of covet
denial that I had at the beginning of
the pandemic where I was you know I
can't stop making my TV show we're all
going to get it anyway we can't just
stop working we can't shut down the
World We Can't Stop flying and then I
smoked DMT and had this image of MC
escher's
on the fence with Joe I guess sometimes
she speaks pure Brilliance then he blows
it up really small I feel exactly the
same thing
we're living this Twisted crappy new
agey time where nothing spiritual is
clear
yeah I but I think I've I've said that a
few days ago in one of my tweets uh in
one of my posts on Instagram
uh that
I feel that the the world like
your world is like a niche that you
should discover
you know because when we over generalize
and we're saying like nothing is
spiritual like everything is bad
I think it's because we feel bitter
about the world but
the whole world is too much
and it's up to us whether we we create
our own you know
world within
the world we are experiencing
um
and uh
uh it's a niche that you need to
discover whether that is whether that
means that you have to discover it
through your
um
through your your work through your
friends through like changing the way
you live changing the way you
um
you have fun changing the way you
changing the place where you leave I
mean it's it's it's so easy for me to to
feel disappointed within the premise of
you know
the big city that I decided to call home
and feel disengaged and disconnected and
every time I'm like dude why don't you
just like leave off greed why don't you
just find a community where you can
actually become an active part in that
community and why don't you just like
help them why don't you just like
disengage from this materialistic
um
and uh meaningless mode of being why
didn't you just do it and
and I'm still I'm constantly asking
myself why and uh
there are things that I wanna I wanna do
things that I wanna accomplish that I
cannot do them if I you know disconnect
myself
uh for example uh I told you last time
that uh in my last stream that I'm
studying filmmaking right now and I find
purpose in that
um
I feel that I've been a YouTuber since
like three four years now and
I feel that the next step to the stage
of my Evolution as a as a filmmaker was
a video creator is to become a filmmaker
and because I have like a very artistic
side is the only way that I can express
myself artistically and this keeps me
going you know this creates meaning
within the premises of the society that
I I decided to inhabit and this is what
I call my Niche right
uh and I think that everybody needs to
find find this Niche and once you find
this niche a lot of things that
annoyed you don't really matter anymore
and it's it's uh
it's changed your whole uh experience
Angels and Demons but instead of Angels
and Demons it was pangolins and
Horseshoe bats oh wow and uh and came
out of it and and thought
uh of course I feel horrible of course
this is depressing and confusing this is
actually one of the worst things that
has happened in my lifetime and I just
have to accept it now and I felt so much
more at peace it just Stripped Away the
denial and and I could just say all
right this is happening and
okay nice I love Hamilton Morris
so this video is like The Joe Rogan
Experience the best thing is to get in
this sorry about that this is a 10 year
old video but uh it's it's kind of epic
[Music]
that's how I discovered this guy
um Hamilton Maurice uh
this guy's like uh kind of a
guinea pig he likes to try everything
and have his own experience so he can
you know properly understand how its uh
thing that he tries he's affecting his
body and his uh mind he's a great guy
it's in 2013 after a long and extremely
painful night I was sitting tearful in
meditation on my sofa in front of a
two-story tall picture window here if we
bleeding for the hell from the universe
it sounds like a very powerful
experience
hi Kostas how are you man delay
um you missed a lot of stuff like we
started with uh with a video uh my video
called like
sometimes reality if it's like a dream
so we went into this rabbit hole and now
we're talking about uh psychedelics and
we're gonna watch this video
about how you hallucinogenic frogs
yeah
date we could just be Doug Stanhope and
I go Doug Stan hope you're on and just
push you on and to get me into that
state I have to know incorrect what time
I should not be shit-faced like
no no no this this don't take 50 million
um
yeah damn it
oh
um
I don't know
hmm
oh we're live again
are we live yes we're live again right
yeah
uh okay uh yeah sorry about that guys I
didn't know that uh
the vice video I mean I thought that it
was gonna be copyrighted but I don't
know how this stream works sometimes
they let you watch the video sometimes
they don't so I'm gonna try to avoid
that in the future it was a bit too much
I guess
um
anyway
uh as you can see I have so many great
videos uh
piled up but I think I'm gonna call it a
night because I said that today's gonna
be a short stream two to two and a half
hours I've been streaming for like
two hours
uh that's fine but moving forward
um like I'm gonna do shorter streams
more often in the future like I will try
to stream like two or three times a week
uh but depending on the viewership
because
it's a bit tricky with the algorithm the
way the algorithm works and I want to
bring more people on
but today I did like a small mistake
with the link so I posted a different
Link in the beginning and then I joined
a stream that was unlisted so a lot of
people couldn't join and I realized that
during the stream so I couldn't like
stop the stream and start over but
tomorrow I'm not gonna do the mistake is
anyway it's my second stream so you know
you need to be patient with me it's like
little tips like take some time for the
streams to to be to like to to flow
organically but I'm really enjoying them
um I wanted to thank everyone for being
here everyone who
um shared their experiences their
knowledge their wisdom skygazer
[Music]
um
venusian woman
all the amazing people that contributed
in the chat uh you guys are awesome
really really thank you for keeping me
company tonight I hope you enjoyed the
stream like we're still in the beginning
we're gonna be the streams are gonna be
better uh like everything is going to be
better than the previous one and yeah
thank you uh have a good night have a
good day whatever you are
um and yeah see you all tomorrow
bye